hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to drunk minecraft this is
definitely the first time we've done
this no we haven't done this at all oh
no we didn't screw up ten minutes we by
I mean by Phil who is with us here hey
this is Phil that's not skin but he died
so it doesn't work right
anyway that's Phil he's from a fire UK
some bigshot Channel wow you son of a
[ __ ]
some down these fireworks hey I'm from
Fire UK what did you expect uh ah haha
oh good it's that Christmas joke that we
didn't say before because we're not an
idiot and didn't forget or record our
audio
oh okay so yeah um wait what the hell
Bob yeah Bob is here and wait is not so
I we're very happy about that
I'm drinking Jack Daniels ah honey Jack
and what are you drinking Phil I am
drinking Jager and monster things
together and then I'm moving on to
Desperados which is beer flavored with
tequila oh look there's snowman on the
cones look snow golems oh look crit Wow
ah are you doing so we're on Hoth this
is our Christmas special this is our
Christmas tree um hi guys you think you
should go we should go explore all over
this way let's not go over there that
looks shitty oh okay we have no reason
to think there's anything over there oh
okay all right yeah there probably isn't
but unless you do for some reason me we
should you know there might be something
here what makes you think that I I don't
know just my Spidey sitting you should
elaborate I you know oh wait I see glass
oh no what could it mean I don't know
whoa is that uh is that the hearth base
oh it could be rebels got whoa look at
this Wow okay
oh okay our weight no I'm alive down
here somehow
haha I made it I have one heart I felt
through the hole that I didn't see that
you made but you make a hole there I
don't know I didn't see the hole either
I didn't make it
anyway yeah the Pearl which I did not
carry on from when we did not record
last time oh yeah I go down okay
totally oh look at these wolves that are
here mysteriously oh no reason
hey will there any way I'm oh this is an
interesting cavern at all but I feel
like we should get out here sobbing but
this feels very familiar yeah Tama get
us out of here
I can wait what's with this explosion
hole in the ground
explosion quick check it out mark oh
okay yeah what's in here huh
let's go introduce up around here that's
just where we were yeah shut up
wha-what I heard some herds um they were
just probably under its hey I see TNT
over there
that's so suspicious you see ti-ti look
right honey you're not seeing that no no
it's round the mountain no no on the
mountain all right there no I'm gonna go
towards it I'm sure nothing bad will
happen
hey snow balls Hey all right so we're
now that we're all situated that wait
that already blew up this is a whole
thing this is our Christmas wait you see
a hole I do not see a hole there like
part of a mountain used to be no I do
not wait I stopped paying attention and
now I'm lost where are you what Wow Bob
no Bob oh there's Bob Bob get over all
right anyway so now that we're caught up
to where we were there not that we were
doing anything before but you know just
now it is christmas pretzel christmas
pretzel it's christmas special yes
pretzel why is my way if I go into my
inventory my avatars lying on the side
and red as if I'm dead no okay so I
found more glass oh okay
wait where oh yeah right there all right
hormone guys I don't know how I'm gonna
make it down I will the snow will push
in my fault I'm going back there I'll
catch you
Oh screw you guys I'm going back to the
house oh that didn't work at all wait
what's going on over the wall some cool
that I should know about you guys
including me
I'm gonna build a snow fort around your
stuff so no one takes it but did you die
how did you die
I was jumping I'm bald didn't catch me
oh okay alright I don't know what's the
catch button right towards me and then
like are sounding teleporting request
cancelled what that lots of walk around
yeah oh so anyway um Wade is not here
like we've said so he's off with his
girlfriend - yeah I know
who Kunie who needs a girlfriend right
right Oh Phil I like my girlfriend's
right Phil do you are you I shouldn't
laugh at her that's me
no no you well I mean you know
girlfriends aren't everything because
you know way does a girlfriend and look
at him I mean God I mean come on that's
wait I know do you wait what does it say
about me if Wade can go girlfriend and I
can no no see I don't have a girlfriend
either but that means we're cool right
cool right why are we following Bob in
this thing I don't know anyway I'm
making a nice tunnel
Oh whoo take your other shot I've
already taken four shots already so this
is my fifth one already already yeah
already already already yeah here we go
depressing fat honey boo boo child's
mother has a as it has someone has well
yeah she had a baby yeah she is
Papa Bear don't ever think all of this
she's not going on air I don't know
but do you why are we in here I don't
know I do follow me I'm dumb hang on
okay
in this barren wait I said something X
no I didn't I mean I'm gonna say
something existential about the
interpretations of this landscape and
how it reflects on the barren wasteland
I'd say well they'll say something
interesting quick there's nothing
interesting out here yeah
isn't Hoth completely disappeared it
isn't this gonna be pretty no no no
there's got to be a rebel zero somewhere
I guess in my shot I'm taking my shot
who's taking it with me
I'll take one with you okay I will drink
are we gonna do one together cuz oh you
know you know you know it Bob did you
read up all the comments on our last
video you mean the ones about how
everyone was so pissed about not having
face cams no no about how they they
didn't like like they were thought we
were not drunk and oh you mean all the
people who didn't watch all the way to
the end and thought that we went insane
for no reason yeah
are a complete shift in personality
obviously means we've changed who we are
what's wrong with these guys this is
obviously not how they usually act
[ __ ] what a bunch of [ __ ] I
wanted to post what's that guy from The
Simpsons that the Arnold Schwarzenegger
could type guy and he says when he's
doing his stand-up routine
he's like a joke I wanted the most what
what what I missed it I haven't even
taken my shot I was talking what do you
do I'm dead now how did you die from
that there was our hole okay now the
explosion maybe fall can't come down
eggs ice Josh good mate uh-oh you here
is just the clinking of glasses clink
ease right I have a trash can full of
beer bottles next to me ah
so well my thumping noises is me putting
stuff back down your thumping noises
yeah that anyway so it sounded wrong no
better no Mosca being brave no no back
up the dog that's knocked out here so
yeah you're you're you're British right
yes you're British
okay well I was clutch but oh yeah wait
wait a sec yeah oh yeah Scottish yeah
who the same thing same thing it's all
the United Kingdom or whatnot you know
oh hold all the same riffraff that's not
what no all right I was looking at this
thing for chant is like there's this
really picture this really British guy
this weird ass beard and he was like I'm
so British I [ __ ] the Queen ha ha ha
that never I'm not that British no no
okay
well you're never that or I've flown
like several monarchs down the tube and
the pipe works and I should really go to
prison for treason ha ha ha God there
was there was a bunch of things that you
know
fun because Americans call things
different like the rooty tooty a Manchu
recall gun the web was the Wibbly wham
Lee Dorsey
KaBlam Lee I don't know some weird weird
you I could find it I could probably
find it what are you talking about no
don't trust for Chapman they're talking
about other countries
no no 4chan is my one source for news
you know you know you know for ten it's
good right Bob black man can go wrong
yes not any worse than watching Fox
neither so oh haha hope all's I need to
get rid of so I'm gonna take a quick
fishing to you guys okay
wait what I don't know I lost you so I
was on I'm [ __ ] so yeah uh all right
there you're right there Phil very
differently can't go any lower than wait
no maybe wait is it going there in the
UK right now is no it's raining rain
Allah what race all the time in HK
seriously half our nation is under water
at the moment like my town was on like a
news as well like nation news because
it's under war and flooded are you dead
no okay oh yeah I live on a hill I'm
smart well good I'm shaking the people
that don't aren't smart that's really
offensive oh yeah did I oh that's pretty
it's terrible there's a there's a moon
oh it's a witch that's no witch
I don't know anyways just poison I don't
rip this little balls kill witches I
don't know mark I need to set you on
fire to get rid of that to get rid of
the wide I don't think you can light
snow on fire oh hello oh ha ha ha bars
ah I'm not the winner you shouldn't be
burning me oh my god I survived oh my
god I live I'm living because someone is
mysteriously healing me mmm I wonder who
that could be
anyway I don't remember if in if we
covered the topic of your channel yet
Phil oh my channel did we no no yeah we
talked about that the dough let's look
at it again did did we don't know how am
i dying ha oh hello
why did all your stuff just fall onto me
Martha I don't know don't ask me anyway
I'm back at home
so um Phil tell us about your channel in
what you do our channel we do stuff yeah
like Minecraft mostly yeah um people may
know us from our time lapses of the
stuff we've worked with lots of cool
people like CaptainSparklez and
syndicate and hat films and Mojang and
those people you've actually worked with
Mojang yeah really did that we did a
project for Mojang in the UN hey saving
the world and stuff yeah so this guy's
sonic big shot yeah yeah you know so
good for him yeah this year with my
modest channel hey wow you are in one of
our awesome hardcore series right we
still haven't put released in a while
yeah I mean you're trying to do more or
less play stuff right overall yeah yeah
well I feel bad because like most of our
stuff like takes so long to get released
that I want to make sure that people
have something in in between yeah yeah
that's good yeah it's good to have so I
want to try I mean I've been really oh
my god what the haha yeah ah that's the
giant zombie by the by throat elbow that
it huh duh no huh
goddamn ass no huh go yeah uh-huh
focus almost I got plenty of snowballs
ah Thank You zombie for filling my
inventory with snowballs I really
appreciate that
i'ma shoot fireworks at it yeah run away
uh-huh
it's killing yeah kill it with no good
ro use fireworks duh yeah we uh huh well
how are you
oh I got a text nevermind I'm sorry if I
actually got kicked by this thing I'd be
like flying there we go
I defeated the Beast well good on
diamonds hey where what what you the
ground
yeah I'm digging what I feel like this I
got forward of this barking we're
walking around this barren landscape
needs a new equation we can we get
strips of TNT
huge swathe cuz I feel like this is too
uniform a landscape I would love like
just enormous swaths I'm going to ground
Wow
there we go yeah yeah come in my hole oh
I'm gonna leave now
haha oh god okay yeah what are you guys
laughing no this TNT so funny
okay alright so that's what I was
laughing at - yeah also I got tea I got
Flint steel so I'm gonna here we go yeah
oh this is aa B ah you ready Bob no I'm
gonna die no you're far enough away oh
god you're such a liar what what how did
you get hit you're over oh no that's
Phil no that's you we've landed next to
me what oh you're just unlucky on
yeah there's amo at the stream haha haha
haha silly your theory Americans oh oh I
died did not die he you seem fine yeah
okay yeah this is better okay so Oh
Brewed almighty left the game brew
nobody join the game alright so I got
these disconnected because of something
you guys did what what what could have
that have been you need a better oh my
god ah this is nothing nothing most mug
most of what drum guy craft is is just
ending up where we start blowing things
up and how much we're playing take it or
tecnique so we could get nukes yeah or
cataclysms or whatever those things were
at occlusives yeah that's still one of
the funniest things I've ever done
yeah yeah yeah yeah ah ha ha ha how do
you like it alright so Ayla yeah so we
are doing a Christmas fete I feel like
we should do something Christmas
shouldn't we uh see we should we should
build you do on Christmas do you do on
an average Christmas Day
wake up Chinese food yeah I did that
last Christmas actually I went to a
Chinese restaurant for dinner actually
you know what I'm doing this Christmas
why not to change the topic completely
but I'm seeing Django Unchained comes
out a lot Christmas suppose like the
best movie that's ever been made
really hey guys what ha what ha what was
the um that was where's that did it look
was it wait that means I'm not actually
Wade ha ha ha well uh right it what was
that Wade I don't know it's a Ford
minion right yeah Lord minion 777 that's
his name that was yeah that's great huh
all the latest JD I hope he dies his
ghost Oh
flying is not available on this server
yeah that's EIT is glitched I'm not
gonna go near last why I disconnected
before ok staying away from that here
here here over this way over this way
where what I so do not see you what a
sit down I saw TNT flying up to the sky
ha ha ha what happened I missed it I saw
there was like I just felt like the
crest of like a halo turns out it went a
lot deeper Oh God going off what the
hell yeah my oh god oh god oh no oh no
oh no oh no wait
have mercy no why are we being haunted
by Wade I know he's not dead is he
he didn't maybe oh oh my god oh no Molly
met with Molly I see another one
no Bob does what happened he met with
Molly and Molly was real of psychopathic
murderer
and she murdered him you know that's a
possible murder Bonnie it's totally
possible it's just not you know I know
Molly right you'd know Molly why no
Molly too but yeah sure we all know
Molly but do we really know mom yeah
exactly
I'm not enabled ha ha ha good I don't
want a fly I'm getting out of here
there's too much TNT here this is just
ridiculousness
oh I don't have so many snowballs Oh
scares us be in golden armor and I'm
gonna die again I'm going over to this
weird mountain right guys there's
something over here oh look look oh it's
just a hot face I don't know maybe I
never had enough finger mountains or
maybe you should shut up okay so I will
explore first I will set off fireworks I
I will make us a snow bridge
oh my god Bob don't move you've got an
arrow in your eye might well I don't
want to tell you but well let me kind of
I can't see it kind of looks like your
penis there the arrow does no aah
oh it's NSP we're far above penis jokes
here Phil I mean I Lee I've rushed this
show before you know that rice is a high
class okay never mind then how's parkour
al Tim to work is there something in
here that we're supposed to find Oh get
over there Wow look he's coming right at
me oh sweet baby Jesus oh my god I'm
like that it's Jay Jay Jay oh my god Oh
think of how many that will split in two
Oh give me a sword oh you have a son
don't you know I am I find it
sweet baby Jesus has to quote Bob Bob
did you say that
those you but you said sweet you say
sweet baby's use right occasionally okay
alright so he robbed of ha I can't even
hit it God need to go uh-oh its but it
wait it dropped a goopy hang on I'm
gonna get this thing I'm gonna kill this
dead wah it's what you might have hit it
and it split it
oh god it's freaking oh my god Oh what
did I'm throwing snowballs at it good
they appear to go directly through it oh
it's like it's some sort of gelatinous
fluid huh squish squish creature which
seems to be a setting some sort of weird
green ooze oh man
you sounded just like that guy who ever
you know bring don't someone cheap knock
ha ha ha I stayed up here I guess I'm
back home now oh oh it's not self oh did
you die - OH
yep great oh yeah I'm here alone yeah
Bob don't even have any equipment Bob
we're gonna sing Christmas carols
instead of faces got victory go Bob go
you got it oh you got it you got it yeah
good job oh I'm home now wait I didn't
explore what's resting this is an
upstairs anything interesting oh there's
a bed that's boring that's boring
where's anything else huh boring what's
at the bottom here Bob what's down there
uh whatever it is don't go down there
I'm going down there I'm down here going
down stumping down here is there nothing
down here there's a room down this goes
pretty far down it's really dark in here
oh there is something here oh oh it's
this place oh do we ever stop to realize
that we might already be at the base oh
no oh no impossible alright so I'm going
back up anyway we need to celebrate
Christmas or whatever nondenominational
holiday that are celebrating Kwanzaa
Kwanza that's not nondenominational that
is very dunno today was Festivus
Festivus was a specific holiday for the
rest of us oh you're a dick so you are
Wade uh-oh
all right so what can we do that would
be of great celebration we could give
each other presents wait a minute
this doesn't seem right where'd this
would come from huh y-you know there's
old some believe it's up one no no I
can't get out anyway cuz you broke the
letter so I'm not even trying to help
Bob but fell or Wade wait be such an
[ __ ] look at this I got you away
I got your Bob go go jump jump Bob Bob
jump hi I'm John that's all I got han
wait put that one down one below I'll
dig ma who did that I how did that I got
that Bob move a second move I'll move
there we go okay get out Bob no Bob move
got Bob there I go okay oh look a few
minutes those editing those shots are
hitting me right now I took five in the
span of about 40 minutes uh uh hi guys
let me see what happens when I jump from
really really high okay gu making a try
a tree oh we are okay yeah yeah I'm
gonna start it so I'm already helping hi
on style like minecraft doesn't do this
automatically for you know redwoods and
whatnot but yeah let's do this
shut up mark yeah but see we're part of
our UK so like you know we do must
exhale oh okay we should tie them laughs
build this tree Hey Wow look at the view
from up here you can see all the you
know snow and stuff oh yeah totes
yeah really then there's literally
nothing you shut your face anyway let's
not even see the house anymore
what Jesus I'm trying to build two at a
time and you
you [ __ ] - eating I'm going to one
screw you got ya how much what did you
have well I still got four full stacks
Oh
oh man look I can't even see the ground
anymore uh okay yeah yo you need out
your view distance man here here you
want pro like I am and I can see for
miles
there I gave you would this is rather
wha wait why are you doing here no this
is impossible
you guys see this I was recording the
video for this I cut that was awesome
looking up and then I look straight back
down
did you see wait or was I just going
crazy there I can't see the ground so oh
I didn't just see wait I see the barely
outline if I don't have you know I don't
have my zoom function at the moment cuz
I don't have Optifine right now pick
anything big letters to go up I don't
know uh good luck with that I'm stuck
here too so I don't there no more build
height restriction not in this server I
will own a [ __ ] and see you mark I'm in
taste you're gonna catch me okay
yeah okay that's me are you sure here I
come Wow
yeah that's me what's a hell man it to
me I put my life in your hands going are
you guys looking at the giant tree that
we just made yeah yeah what's up I'm
about to jump off okay so my alright
okay I'll catch up okay - better than
better than Phil did okay yeah sure sure
you really think I think I'm jumping up
number alongside that's facing the house
okay okay okay by the Christmas tree I
think okay all right go go man go ha ha
where are you
no see you don't see there is Rui you're
on the wrong side ha ha
I could have got you your dad okay so
anyway we go will ya like four minutes
left we gotta do something Christmasy Oh
Oh God oh gosh we should sing wookie
Christmas oh yeah
Oh
oh I sound like the mesh man that's not
right I sound like run from amnesia
ok I'm done I'm back I'll probably doing
probably without annoying guys probably
probably probably won't know till I get
feedback later then who cares I'm gonna
build I've got ladders I'm gonna climb
the tree again uh why because it's not
finished uh okay I'm almost back at the
time you took all the wood no you should
have a bet I've come have it all
I'm coming after you you can't have all
the woods no no you're building up
another part of the tree what is this
301
yeah he's barred it he built another
side of it Oh coming after you our trees
gone louder no no no this started to a
really weird activity
you know that's reminds me uh vomit
thing where he's like putting down the
track like as the trains going this is
what's happened right now you're the
penguin God Walter that's so British oh
my god I'm at the topic of you well the
way it's framed right now the Sun is
like dead noon so it's right at the top
of this giant tree it's actually going
to the Sun it's the Sun tree who these
kids are building a stairway to heaven
interested and she's been lit their way
to heaven well let's think of the South
Park episode but yeah where's a ladder
to heaven knows it letter oh I found one
what's that what is that what the hell
whoa what's happening what is up there
what is that what is the what is that
what's what what's your ass okay never
right that's what those Phil's ass oh no
no what that is what is that an anvil
he's dropping anvils on us Oh what did
it done hurt [ __ ] keep going keep going
I'm at 350 for that's our build Lily I
made it I made it I made it you made it
okay
I managed to grab a hold it a lot about
pretty good for you 55 hey get those
ladders up here you asked woo Howard I
guess haha I guess if I work so I'll be
how many fireworks can you light off at
once I'm actually curious
oh I see them keep keep lighting them no
magical let's just run off right by my
I'm just gonna be inside you right now
oh oh yeah comment by hole I see the
wood I'm raining down on you what no we
do not it's raining wood okay it's rain
it would hold it would never say go
saver side one other side why I love it
oh I see
ha I made it okay hahaha
what is it Looney Toons Jesus oh I just
remembered
most of the age of my viewers isn't old
enough to know what Looney Tunes is what
no way yeah the average age of my
viewers like 15 I think I thought why
why is it on fire iswhat on fire ha the
tree tree on fire wha what did you do
all right we're actually out of time so
I don't think we did anything Christmasy
unless is on a star on top so the top of
the Train give me a star hat ah Phil you
[ __ ] I can't get up there I don't have
any wood zombie porn a tatami did you
select you need to get to it though but
wait I'm at the top hand okay I got this
bad given what needs to record it no
yeah no we're out of time give me a star
quick what is this what I'm have a star
all I have is wooden fire yeah I got
something oh I got something I got
something hang on where's the top of
this Sun bit hunters I got lots of
letters hey Mark Oh Kelly crap we all
made it to the top move move move move
out of that center block move boom wait
how is that it's a beacon it's actually
Christmas mother [ __ ] all right
that's it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching this has been phil from fire UK
Bob and me and not Wade who is not here
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always we will see
in the next video Oh what is that oh
dude oh dude you don't look so good
listen I want to stop doing now Oh